Well, our story starts in 1981.
A small software company called Microsoft hit it big with a text-based operating system...
...called MS-DOS for IBM's new personal computers.
DOS was efficient for the time,...
...but the average computer user wanted something more accessible.
So, Microsoft used an internal product called Interface Manager...
...to put a graphical face on DOS.
Cut to 1985 and you got Windows 1.0.
This really is a great product.
It may look crude but this first version of Windows was pretty revolutionary.
It brought us the things we know and love to this day:...
...drop-down menus, scroll bars, icons and dialog boxes.
It also used this new device called a mouse.
To help users practice their mousing skills, version 1.1 included the game Reversi.
Can you believe it? Reversi!
In 1987, Windows 2.0 arrived with better graphics, including overlapping windows.
One year later, Microsoft became and stayed the largest PC software maker.
Vista ended up being a terrible mess of glitches.
It took Microsoft two years to fix the mess it had made with Windows 7,...
...a product finally good enough to convince most people to move from XP.
In 2012, Microsoft tried to be radical again with Windows 8.
It did away with the traditional desktop and replaced it with tiles,...
...which attempted to bridge PCs, laptops, tablets and smartphones.
Most people were confused and went back to the familiar desktop.
And what about Windows 9?
I don't know, what about it?
Today, we have Windows 10.
It takes us back to the familiar desktop and start menu.
And it's free.
This will also probably be the last time Microsoft puts a number on Windows.
Going forward, Windows will just be Windows.